quel beau projet que un projet de vie et
la mobilité peut faire partie d'un
projet de vie de tous citoyens notamment
des personnes comme nous qui vivons ici
à la réunion dans une île éloignée des
grands centres métropolitains et je
voudrais vous dire combien je suis
heureux que vous ayez été sélectionnés
parmi tant d'autres candidats
félicitations à vous parce que vos
mérites vos compétences ont été reconnus
mais aussi vos talents et ce qui est
reconnue aussi c'est cette volonté de
sauter la mer et pour cela il faut du
courage
alors bravo à toutes celles et à tous
ceux qui ont été retenus
mes félicitations et bien sûr je vous
encourage parce que vous avez cette
chance de pouvoir trouver une
association par l'activité économique à
métropole je salue votre engagement je
salue aussi le travail qui est réalisé
par le cnom notre partenaire historique
sur ce volet de la politique de mobilité
et le travail remarquable qui est fait
par le cnam ses services et biens porte
ses fruits
je voudrais aussi saluer la mobilisation
de tous les partenaires
si vous vous déplacez à la réunion c'est
aussi un signe de reconnaissance que la
réunion est une terre de l'excellence et
grâce à notre partenariat entreprise
normes département de la réunion
et bien c'est l'excellence réunionnaise
qui reconnut et à travers vous eh bien
ce n'est pas seulement vous que je veux
encourager
c'est aussi votre famille parce que ce
le choix il les fait pas vous mais il
vous engage il engage le reste de votre
famille alors je ne peux que saluer
cette volonté qui vous anime et cette
volonté qui va vous guider dans la
réussite de votre papa de vie j'aurais
aimé être parmi vous aujourd'hui mais
j'ai tenu à vous exprimer ma solidarité
et mon envie de vous accompagner dans ce
nouveau challenge qui vous attend
félicitations quand et pleine réussite
à toutes et à tous